I feel that this country is a little bit
desensitized there are still folks out
there right now fighting there are still
folks out there right now dying and
there's a lot more people that forget
that what does Memorial Day mean to me
it's another day that I have to remember
it shouldn't be about 3-day sales on
sofas or cars or let's go barbecue
because the start of summer it's
honoring those a mermaid those that have
paid the ultimate sacrifice life is so
precious and an end so quickly you know
it's just one day he's there and he's
not my best friend know so I pushed
forward cuz of him his memory on
Memorial Day I don't just think of my
friends that died in her at graphic I
understand I think about my friends that
have died from their battles back home
you know I prot
I've lost more friends to suicide than I
have to combat at this point
some people are resistant to the idea of
serving in the military because they
don't like our foreign policies I'm not
fighting a war for oil whatever the
political agenda is of different
military objectives isn't why I chose to
sir
it's never about the politics for me
after after my first appointment it
stopped being about politics it became
about the men and women next to me
that's all was these are people that
come from all different walks of life
I remember just a good old southern boy
and I'm hanging out with uh some with a
California dude or some New Yorker and
it's a melting pot just a melting pot of
people from all over the world
that's like blood sweat and tears
together you're - you're never alone
you're always have your battle buddy to
the right and left and and we make so
many friends it's just a camaraderie and
just a sense of brotherhood sense of
family I learned a lot while I was
deployed mainly about a lot about myself
be honest you um I was I was married I
just had a child right before I joined
and it was rough being awake it really
it really was I miss him more than I
care to at that time to tell people I
definitely learned not to quit you know
I learned that there's gonna be
situations there's gonna be times that
test you and push you to your limits and
you need the proper training in practice
rigorous training and practice to really
bring your best self out when you're at
your worst the people in Iraq they're
here was shown like there were our
enemies you know but over there they're
just the same as us they didn't
understand the war it wasn't part of
them you know there was more politics I
guess you know when I put on that
uniform it's almost like I'm not just
putting on for me or my family it's for
those who have served before me and
or they're all part of a team we're all
a family and that's why Memorial Day
means that much thing